основна ідея нової української школи c та
дієту що свист і базу та ціни
компетентному підходи та
і так само методи навчання на
компоненті знову підході та
- починаємо картинки буде завершена
концепції роботу над стандартами та нові
українські школи і відразу мило що за
перельоті стандарті можна буде прохати
оранка їх покладемо які вже сьогодні у
описі і в законі, і в концепції
уявлень національної академії
педагогічних наук
за нашими планами проведення діти ведуть у
перший клас такий та нові українські
школи у 2018 2019 урок якраз до того
години травня бути затверджений стандарт
дільничні школи розрубані про
пілотування програми для великого
класу і тільки в результаті ми можемо їх треба
вата для всієї України
вулиці пудами 1719 розуму початковому роді
проти повз нього цілий шквал критики
зістрибнути шинних програм чітко ви і
школи та самокритика швейних програм
хоче кови та школи привела нас до
розуміння того що ми йшли краще cottage
нових стандартів треба
берліну ці програми на предмет їх про
such as на неї на предмет побачивши немає
вікових особливостей дітей на предмет
масштабу раз монтажі не займу
теоретичну інформацію sublime на
купиш
у класі тоді в тюрму пішому циклі ж
за рф щоб бачити річки сьогодні я в
качанах школі могли score is that i вигляд
такого року хлопець програма sweet на
випадок ну string у мене облич і буквально
ми пікшу куди ви муся норріс не hause та
як забувається інформація США 5 руки в
тому і за раз у шиї ви краще з
нарізаєте так само чи змінюється ти так
сама змінюється з mist всяким он з
стікаються з виду на колони там та
сьогоднішньому жвавому полоненому світлі на
адже 5 руки
з ж валики змін і
їм йому до школи нацизмі не робот